hey guys welcome to the Ruben report I
am Dave ruin and according to this paper
I have two fantastic guests with me two
of my favorites actually shaa Malcolm
YouTube sensation and Jimmy door also
YouTube sensation comedy sensation etc
etc and we got to get right to it so
here we go publishing sensation and he's
got a new book which we're going to get
to a little bit later pretty fancy fancy
all right here we go so President Obama
is on a three-day fundraising Tour on
the west coast starting today going for
the next uh two days and he uh is
getting a lot of heat from people
because I don't know if you guys know
about this but there are some problems
in the Middle East have you heard about
that there's some situation going on
with Gaza and Israel I don't know if you
heard about the plane and Russia and
Ukraine and we have this border thing
and Rick Perry sending troops or
something down there there's a lot of
going on in the world right now and
our second term president is doing three
days of fundraising and apparently just
bought a house in Palm Springs to retire
in uh after his presidency so he's
getting a lot of crap about this and uh
well we've got a little bit more info
about some of the stuff he's doing over
the next couple days so based on
descriptions of Obama's fundraisers from
democratic officials uh he could raise
over $6 million during the trip which
comes at the same time as I said of the
Israeli ground invasion in Gaza and all
this stuff with the jetliner over
Ukraine so it's sort of an estimate that
he could raise around 6 million it could
be a little bit less could be a little
bit more um but forgetting the numbers
like is it bad Optics is this just bad
like what's he do this is a second term
guy he's not even raising the money for
himself he's raising it for the party
this just seems bad to me I mean it it
does come across as in poor taste but at
the same time it's not as though I'm
fervently convinced there would have
been doing anything anyway about the
situations anywhere else in the world
yeah had he not been fundraising so it's
a great cover for not wanting to do
anything so there's that right so Jimmy
we talk about money in politics a lot is
this just like this just part for the
course right this is just what they do
no matter what's going on no I think
this is a legitimate criticism CU if you
remember uh when George Bush was
president he didn't fundraise and he
fixed Katrina like that and he wasn't F
if he wouldn't so that's how Iraq got
fixed so yeah so apparently if Barack
Obama wasn't out here raising funds that
he could fix everything right just like
if this he could fix everything if he
just had a third term can't get
fixed now but if other things were
different everything would get fixed so
that's sort of a defensive what's going
on here if I'm reading you correctly
Barack Obama fundraising I think it's uh
well overall it's horrible that we have
a system where the president needs to
fundraise in the middle of a crisis yes
overall we need to change that system I
thought Barack Obama was going to be a
bigger Force to change that system turns
out he's not he's just one of the boys
so that's I guess the sad part we all
thought hope and change like we're going
to really change the system and that
clearly so yes he still has phones as
they as they keep saying the Press SEC
keep saying he's got phones he's got the
internet he can call Putin and he can
call Netanyahu but it still just doesn't
it just doesn't sit with me well am I
just am I I'm I just feel like you know
what dude three days of fundraising
right now really I guess you know course
go I'm sorry no no at the end of the day
I it comes back to there's never been a
strong policy I I don't believe at least
historically for PE for presidents doing
something about International crises
until it's so far escalated that it's
like if you don't get involved now
you're a complete oh so that's
the policy we need this we need this
to all get worse it has to be like
the the bottom of the freaking barrel
and then oh we're going to step in now
yeah yeah well depending on what time it
is well depending on what time well you
don't want to rush it it could it could
have hit it right now all right let's
look a little bit more about who he's
meeting on these
fundraisers uh his first stop is at the
home of developer Bruce Bloom to benefit
the DNC he's going to headline an event
hosted by Jim senagal who's a co-founder
of Costco uh which will benefit the
Senate majority pack cuz we all love
these packs and he'll attend fundraisers
at the homes of Scandal Creator and the
CEO of Live Nation also to benefit the
DNC um yeah power to the people power to
the people Democrats they're all about
the people right but that's what they
say right they're supposed to be more
for the people so if this was a
Republican president Jimmy wouldn't you
be angry yes I would because I'm a big
hypocrite no at least you can admit it
that's all that matters I mean I I don't
know um I really I did I I did criticize
George Bush for being at the fundraiser
during Katrina I certainly did do that
but this is a that was a crisis
happening in America right these are
crisis happening uh in other countries
which he really has limited he can't
really do anything about him anyway and
I say about the Border If there really
is a crisis at the border how come we
haven't bombed the
Border good point thank you good point
you we needed to think on that one a
second just for a second there was a
little there was a little thinking there
um is it is it clear to you guys that
being president is sort of just not what
we thought it was I think that the more
I watch what this presidency has been
like I like the guy he plays basketball
he seems cool I'd like to hang out with
him but the more that I just watch
what's going on here it just seems to me
the president no matter who it is it's
the same if it this was a
republican it would be the same like the
guy would be doing the same thing and
just not much changes but it it it's for
me proof that the system itself is
broken the system itself is broken cuz
if you take someone that you have faith
in uh while they're campaigning and you
can say I can see the change is going to
happen and this is going to be amazing
and it's going to be so different and
then fast forward four or seven or
however many years in and it's the same
on a different day or same
different president yeah it gets you
thinking that it's a system that is so
bogged down with the politicking of
being president that you can no longer
effectively do your job I think you just
hit it that's why I'm so disappointed
with him cuz we all had these High Hopes
I voted for the guy twice so that's why
I'm so disappointed cuz if this had just
been some other guy it would have been
like yeah okay it's just another guy
doing the same old but because of
the hope and change even the second time
I was still like he's going to be a
little better and he won't be
constrained by an election and yet he's
still doing the same bring us home
Jimmy door well what I like to say is
that we get a choice in America in
politicians right because when Romney
ran against Obama if Romney would have
won we would have got Romney carot but
Obama won so we got Romney care we get a
choice in America your country is Just
Not That Into You which you can read all
about of the new book there you go Jimmy
dory's new book your country's Just Not
That Into You he's got a copy look at it
right there and you can get on iTunes
and all your local bookstores and all
that good stuff wow that was a hell of a
segue for plug Jimmy door okay let's
move on so Michael Sam you guys know
about him uh he is now going to be the
first openly gay NFL player he was
signed by the St Louis Rams this is a
great story it's time hopefully there'll
be some more coming no pun intended and
uh former uh Indianapolis Colts head
coach Tony dungi had some interesting
things to say about Michael Sam and
we've got a
quote he said I wouldn't have taken him
not because I don't believe Michael Sam
should have a chance to play but I
wouldn't want to deal with all of it
it's not going to be totally smooth
things will happen so before we get into
the substance of that just real quick
Tony dunie was the first
African-American coach unbeliev in a
Super Bowl so this is a guy who has
changed things for the better and lived
through some stuff so Jimmy uh let's
start just with that with that angle I
agree with Tony dun that's why I thought
it was crazy when they had Jackie
Robinson in the league such a distract
it was such a dist it was such a
distraction too much of a distra Tony
dunie was so distracted by that gay guy
going in the NFL he crashed his car on
the way to work that day I don't know if
you know that so so that's what he said
it was distraction though he but he has
it both way he to say that I don't I he
should be able to play but I ain't going
to have him cuz he you can't have it
both ways exactly exactly the
fundamental problem with this statement
and when he goes on to try to clarify
the statement I read I read it maybe six
or seven times because I'm like maybe
I'm slow because in the statement he's
like yes I nobody asked me if I believe
he should have the right to play no one
asked me if I thought he deserved it and
I'm like okay so you're agreeing with
all of this right but he just shouldn't
play with you oh okay and I don't think
you get credit for the stuff that's so
obvious you know what I mean
congratulations he can play like you
don't deserve right to live your life
and pursue the American dream oh wait
but not with me okay right right that
that so so what do you guys make of the
now you're African-American am I uh
technically Jamaican but Jamaican okay
there you go that wanted to clarify that
we're in America how about that okay so
what what about that angle of it though
that he as the first African-American
coach to ever win a Super Bowl that he's
been through the the things that have
changed so it's particularly oddd that
he would make this statement and that's
how it came across to me it was actually
very disappointing because unfortunately
we still live in a world and in a
country where uh when where you have a
from minorities one person kind of
speaks for the group so when you see um
someone who's African-American saying
something that isn't in line with your
thought process at all it's like oh
great no but people know more know you
more than they know me they'll think I
think like you no no you know you kind
of have that momentary Panic of I'm not
an idiot I swear yeah so it it's it's
unfortunate and as a representative of
all gay people you know I know I know
what you're saying well you could act a
little gayer than if you're going to be
G I'm just a smidge Jimmy tell me about
what you think about now I know where
you're coming
from so I will say this about Tony dunie
now I grew up in a kind of very racist
neighborhood and uh what he was he says
about says about the gays is what a lot
of racist say about blacks they go oh no
I I work work with them but uh and they
should be able to live whereever they
want but not next door to me right or I
love black people I work but they can't
date my daughter it's that kind of a
thing right and so that I love them I'll
go to church with them but they can't
live in my neighborhood you know it's
that he's say that's what he's saying
hey he should be able to live somewhere
he should be able to play somewhere just
not next to me he's not my that's a
really really good I didn't even do that
well that was that's not even good what
is that that's like half Paul I yeah um
okay the irony is he also goes on to
talk about how he
in terms of how did he put it I I don't
want to paraphrase poorly but
essentially he was we'll clean it up but
his point was um how he felt as
though he was trying to be supportive of
gay rights while saying talking about
distractions but creating the
distraction that he was right at the
same time fearful would come about from
having Michael S I'm like yeah so I
think you're on it there cuz I think
what he's trying to say is there's going
to be a media problem you know what I
mean but yet he's the one creating the
so I don't think it's really coming from
anything against gay people I think he's
saying as a I'm giving him a very tepid
defense here just to play Devil's a a
little bit but I think he's trying to
say that yes to bring in an open League
a player sadly at this point is go
there's going to be a media circus now
he's creating the media circus at the
same time but isn't this just why we
need people to just be out and that's it
and hopefully this one thing will'll
have to deal with this for a season and
then next season five guys will come out
and it'll be big goddamn deal and that's
it but the reason it's it's grating for
me still is because look at he's in that
position where he knows that the
attention is often focused not on the
game but on people's personal lives or
race or or um sexual orientation so
inste instead of with that using that
awareness to not channel the focus in
that direction that's exactly what he
did so he's aware of how this plays out
and still goes you know because he's gay
I wouldn't want to deal with that you
just are feeding the same problem so two
can I say two quick things by the way I
was in Africa they and they you know
what they call black people there
Africans it's weird they don't even call
them African-Americans how do I get away
with that I don't know but uh I
forget the other thing I was going to
say the other point don't worry about
that uh quickly do I have to issue any
sort of apology to the good people of
Jamaica I've been to Jamaica wonderful
place I didn't mean to uh you know I
think we'll be fine because you
represent all all of them the Jamaicans
all right there you so Jamaicans don't
be offended you know what you know what
was a distraction when what's the guy's
name the player Michael Sam Michael Sam
he did I heard he did put a glory hole
in the shower room was not right so that
that's a little bit of a distraction
well you know depends how good of a time
you want to have and on that note uh in
New York City 40 Riverside Drive on the
upper west side it's near my old
stomping ground uh they are putting up a
building that is going to have a
separate entrance for the lower income
people yeah this is not made up it
sounds made up separate but equal uh I'm
not sure uh so basically they're putting
up this building uh is being built by a
company called extel and they're going
to have a certain amount of affordable
housing which sounds great and the
reason they're doing this is if you put
in some affordable housing then they let
you build bigger buildings so that
sounds good to them they want to make
more money uh but the people that will
be living in the affordable housing will
also not have access to the gym not have
have access to the pools yeah two
there's more than one pool there uh etc
etc and the affordable housing tenants
make 60% or less of the median income uh
and we've got some some more info on
it uh the city approved a proposal from
xtel and New York City developer to
install separate door for tenants living
in affordable housing units to enter the
building I can't believe we're not
making this up extel applied the
inclusionary housing program which
allows developers to construct bigger
properties if the property includes
affordable units for Less wealthy
tenants as I just said and it's going to
be 55 units that will be designated as
affordable housing facing the street and
uh 219 units will face the river so also
if you get the affordable housing uh you
don't get the good view
this is obviously completely Bonkers but
is this one of those things where sort
of well-intentioned plans just go
completely arai like the idea we were
going to have affordable housing on the
upper west side Riverside Drive nice
area uh and then it just becomes
something terrible I just uh you know I
when I see a story like this I'm like
man it is about about time right cuz I
am so how can we there's there a way for
millionaires to insulate themselves from
the penny list I hope so I really hope
so and I hope those people don't start
buying houses and crash our economy
again that's the poor people buying the
anyway it's a do we need this is this is
not a bad idea going bad this is a good
idea but then the capitalists got
involved so this is a socialist idea
from the government saying hey if you're
going to do this thing and we're going
to give you this amount of property and
you're you're going to be have to help
out people turns out you're going to
have to actually be live in the
community and so they go hey we can find
a loophole and we could actually stick
our Thumb in the eye of poor people and
humiliate them which is what you're
supposed to do if you're a rich and
you're a developer right I enjoy it
right because in America if you have
money you're obviously a great person no
matter how you made it that's a sign of
you're a worthy person and that's why
I'm scum yes if you're poor it's a moral
failing in America that's how we look at
it it's the opposite of what Jesus said
again I'm scum I I know this from
personal experience total Godless scum
soulless soulless completely yeah
separate entrance it's literally like a
ter episode of down ABY when I read this
story I was like what year is this are
you kidding me is this the so that's the
servants quarters and you come in
through the back and I I I was livid
initially and then I got to reading more
about it and I was like wow so they
can't use the pools either and I was
like I guess that's better than oh you
can only use that pool cuz that would be
the colored pool you know what I mean or
the gay pool you see what I'm saying so
I guess it's better to just completely
exclude them and treat them like crap so
for not even for a second would they
think you belong here this may be your
address but you don't belong here but
you don't belong um but also the fact
that the that the actual entrance is on
a side street like they didn't even even
make it like two doors that were kind of
near each other like we have to
literally like hide them in off a side
street but also I was just in New York
City last week I grew up in New York
City like isn't New York City supposed
to be about everybody you know I mean
the rich people get on the subway is
just like the poor people do so this
seems so against not anymore they're not
now they have those fans they got the
they got the Uber they got the they do
not the Uber X what's the fancy Uber
they got the good Uber the lift would
you I just take the X I don't know but
but my point is that this is New York
it's like we are this big mix of
everything and this is just an idea
that's just ripping people apart well
that that's the beauty right so now the
rich people who live in this apartment
building they're going to be bumping in
the poor people all day long except for
that uh twom minute walk up to their
apartment when they get in the front
door I mean I'm by the way I'm sure
there's going to be a janitor who works
there on a door man who's not going to
be as rich as them so they're going to
have to bump into poor people a little
bit a little bit though but at least
those are like employed clean poor
people you know and hopefully they'll
install a separate elevator or at least
just say you can't take the elevator at
all if you're one of those poor ones you
know cuz that's gross should we have any
sympathy for the developer here who in
his mind was probably going I want to I
could just make a small building for
rich people but I'm going to use this
law again Devil's Advocate today man but
you know what I mean he's going but I'm
going to at least use this law to make a
bigger thing and at least get these
people in here but I'm sure there's some
tax benefit I'm sure there are benefit
toell he's able to sell more units but
I'm sure there are other benefits as
well for him financially so you don't
get any sympathy for poor doors I'm
sorry no sympathy for poor let's go from
uh from some rich people to the second
richest person in the world uh Mexican
multi multi- gajillionaire Carlos Slim
he has uh floated the idea of a 3ay work
week I think this is really interesting
let's look at some info
he says with three work days a week we
would have more time to relax for
quality of life having four days off
would be very important to generate new
entertainment activities and other ways
of being uh occupied and now we've got
some info on how he wants to do it uh
the trade-offs would be longer hours
slim suggested putting in as many as 11
hours a day and working into later in
life with a call to push the retirement
age back to 70 or 75 he says these
changes would make the labor Force more
productive while also making it
healthier and addressing the retirement
crisis many workers face later in life
so I mean this actually sounds pretty
good to me three days a week of work
you're going to work a little bit longer
you're going to each day and you're
going to work a little bit later into
life uh I'm kind of on board this thing
and Carlos Slim this guy knows what he's
doing you don't become the second
richest man in the world uh by not
knowing what you're doing right in
theory in theory in theory uh I I I
definitely think there's some Merit to
it but I also think that it
is one it's going to cut hugely into
Walmart's Workforce like hugely that we
and we need to address that because I
mean Walmart we need that to stay people
working minimum wage jobs minimum they
so that Walmart can get government
subsidies to exactly so that was my main
worry I'm like he's not thinking about
the Walmarts right what about them um
but I do think there there is truth to
that when I am most productive is kind
of when I'm not burnt out and there's
something to be said for spending five
days you know tra five days of traffic
and commuting and all of that stuff add
into what is a longer day for people if
people could come in and kind of just
work really hard for 11 hours they did
point out that there were problems with
this in terms of you know people who
work in manual labor jobs you know eight
hours is already a lot right 11 hours
would probably kill them so they
wouldn't make it to the retirement age
but that's their problem again so part
of it it does depend what you're doing
right because if you're lifting heavy
stuff all day yeah it's going to be hard
to tack on another three hours but
there's a lot of people that are just
sitting at their computer Googling all
day right that aren't that aren't doing
that much you you know the problem say
the YouTuber to the other YouTuber to
the other YouTuber so the problem I
think in in America and I've said this
before is that you know we equate in
America with hard work with the harder
you work the better of a person you are
yeah which there there's no correlation
whatsoever because I don't work at all
I'm a great guy right but I did
establish that I'm scum so there is why
I had you guys on together I wanted to
balance it out it's it's it is it's true
I mean people like like to brag about
how much they work they're a hard worker
we're work we're a work adct we're a
bunch this country has a bunch of adult
children of Alcoholics and we don't
recognize our addictions to things and
work is definitely one of them we work
way too much in America you know take a
trip to Spain you know my brother went
to Spain he's like you can't believe it
they take a nap every day for two or
three hours and everything
somehow everything gets done in Spain
right so I I like this guy's idea I
think we need to work less this race to
work even more and more and more and now
we got to uh we have to compete with the
you know third world countries and stuff
like that I I'm with them I say let's
try it I'm done working you're you're
done working so I do think three three
days is a little bit much though I think
four is probably a more reasonable given
the American culture and addiction to
work and the fact that we are an
extremely industrialized country and we
want to stay ahead and we want we have
that drive to be the best be the best I
think it would be very hard to sell oh
let's go down to 3 days of productivity
I think maybe it could push for four
he's never going to sell it it's never
going to happen it'll never happen but
you know you when people in America
they're not even aware of a that people
take cestas in other countries they're
not they're not aware that there's laws
in the European Union for how many hours
someone can work they Capa the hours at
48 or 40 in some countries capped that's
how much you can work plus they all get
a month off a year paid every year
whether you're a bartender or a waitress
or a doctor or to Europe yes so they and
they get a lot of them get more six to
eight weeks off so in America we're
screwed so I would say let's start with
more vacation time for people that gets
on Parallel with the rest of the
industrialized world and then we'll
start scaling back the days but I would
say vacation time so I'm glad you
brought up vacation because I think
we've done stuff on this before I think
we have something like the worst
literally the worst the least amount of
vacation in the industrialized world so
we're already overworking ourselves and
then that was making me think as I said
I just took uh vacation for 10 days that
now because we have these freaking
phones you're working even when you're
not working so now it's like so you
really can't stop so whether they say
it's 3 days at the job or five days at
the job we're all walking around with
this thing and and can do work at all
times so that makes the disconnect even
that much harder right and just as a
last point I'm from a third world
country and my parents when they started
working 20 40 years ago or however many
years ago they were getting you know
four to six weeks of vacation a year and
now that my father is retired of course
he's always vacationing but my my mom
vac has about two months of vacation a
year yeah and then what's the country
are you from Haiti Jama Jamaica Haiti
wow yeah same diff same diff that's a
call back to an earlier segment folks
Jamaica yeah that's a third world
country I didn't know that I've been to
Jamaica I've been to Jamaica too I had a
great week that's that's a whole other
story all right let's move on so Califor
it is a big big state and there is a
plan being floated by Timothy Draper who
is a venture capitalist and he's
invested in a ton of things like Twitter
Hotmail Skype and Tesla uh and he wants
to split California into six different
states that's right let's look at the
states he's proposed Jefferson would
include the northernmost portion South
California would be comprised of San
Diego and Eastern La while the rest of
La would be called West California North
California would be built around
Sacramento Central California would be
made up of the Central Valley Farm
region Silicon Valley would include San
Francisco uh and Silicon Valley would
become the nation's richest state just
by dividing it up just like that they'd
probably like that um so I think this is
kind of interesting because we have a
huge country in the first place you know
what I mean we got a lot of States a lot
of people with different interests and
California is huge California could be a
country many times over uh and its
economies big enough for that um but do
these ideas are they just like pie in
the sky kind of like this this is never
happening right completely pie in the
sky but what's great is I'm sure he's
heavily invested in Silicon Valley and
it's another great poror where he gets
to be all by himself in his like Rich
State all by himself ah so that's what
this is he's investing in all these Tech
startups and he's like I want them to
split off into their own state so then I
can control the taxes and exactly I've
uh advocated this for a long time I I
think that we should not only split up
California we should split up the
country go back to the Civil War and let
them
win you guys win you guys get to leave
all you guys you guys get to leave I
thought you let them take over the no no
they you just want them to let them they
get to separate so then we get to see
what two countries would really be they
get to have their Republican Utopia and
we get to have a regular country so they
get to have a country where you know
there's unregulated oil drilling and
guns on everybody's hip and religion in
every classroom and slaves and slaves
and we and we get to have you know uh
science Healthcare
and all the other good in a clean
environment so I'll I'll take that and
by the way uh I actually am for breaking
up California not no no joke yeah
because we're unrepresented we're under
represented in the Congress right we
only have two senators for California
you go to Wyoming which has a state with
the population less than my
neighborhood yeah they also get two
senators right so they are over
represented and that's what's wrong with
the that's a big problem what's wrong
with legislation in America the people
the
minority uh Viewpoint which is the
Republican Viewpoint way over
represented in the Senate way over
represented just like and also in the
Congress Democrats got a million more
votes than Republicans did yet they
they're way minority in the Congress so
well that's the beauty of redistricting
Jimmy every time you lose an election
you just redistrict it to get it back
the next time isn't it um but so the
Senate thing I think is kind of
interesting because everyone gets two
and that's part of the Constitution but
you know there's supposedly the House of
Representatives then mitigates that
because it is bip population but you're
saying that's not even good that's not
happening it's just not good enough no
no I mean if you look at the Senate I
mean we need the Senate to come along
with the and so the people who represent
no one get to have way more power than
they ever should so it's not one person
one vote it's they get way more than one
person one vote in Wyoming or Montana or
South Dakota any of those po states with
small populaces and they're all
conservative they're all run by
corporations they get way more voice in
our government which is why we have the
situation we have Americans 90% want to
get a gun regulation we all want a
single pair Healthcare we all want to
get uh uh out of uh Afghanistan and IR
that none of that's happening because a
bunch of guys in Wyoming don't want it
to happen that's a direct shot of the
Cheney family if I'm not I'm telling you
I I sounds funny but it's the truth yeah
um is this one of these things where not
only is the country like if you look at
the map of the country where we're blue
you know we're blue around water
basically and then they we're red in the
middle where you want to live that's
where you're blue where wherever you
don't want to live that's the shitty Red
State Park yeah it's kind of true it's
show me a place that's red you want to
live there's no place that I
want to live in a city you liberal
elitists that's what they're saying
about youal even in Texas Houston goes
Democrat and Austin goes in Democrat so
you go to the cities which is where
human beings are supposed to
live yeah you you start to think
normally you have universities you start
to progress you have a progressive
thought right isn't that funny then
during the elections when they're always
he like oh he's from the city he's a
liberal elitist he went to college he
you know what I mean as opposed to what
what do you want do you want some I want
a man of the people who his hands are in
the dirt yes yes yeah I remember I was
watching Matt low on today's show and he
was talking about uh how people uh you
like why is there people from rural
place they're from real America but he's
doing his show in New York City I guess
you can't find a regular Joe anywhere
huh in New York City where's all the
regular people all right this is a great
story and I know this is right up
Jimmy's alley so a grandfather in
England is claiming that he cured his
cancer using cannabis oil so there he is
right there with his cannabis oil he
first had cancer in 2009 and was given a
new liver and the allil clear they said
that's gone but last year new cancerous
cells were found attacking his new organ
and we've got a little more info on what
happened Mike Cutler started taking
cannabis oil after watching a video
about how it could cure him when he went
for a biopsy this year doctors said that
the new cancerous cells had disappeared
in research published last week
scientists at the University of East
Anglia found the main psychoactive
ingredient in cannabis I'm not even
going to try to say that Jimmy you want
to handle that one Tetra hydroc canibol
wow that wow that was really really good
he does love his weed uh had been found
to limit the growth of cancerous selves
uh now interestingly THC basically so
that's that's THC um so interestingly he
describes himself as quote a family man
not a drugie this is someone who found a
natural
Planet this is someone who found a
natural plant and used it for his own
health now of course this this is a bit
uh antidotal I don't know that this
could work for everybody but this is
this is all good why do why are we so
hung up on this cannabis stuff number
one I want to say YouTube saves lives he
saw that video on YouTube yeah YouTube
saves lives we're saving lives people
right now that's what's happening before
your eyes um so I think we're hung up on
it because ultimately weed ganja
whatever you want to call it sorry my
Jamaican is coming out very thick right
now whatever you want to name you know
Mary Jane all the the colloquialisms for
it it is a brown country's drug that's
what it is it the the places that are
quote unquote known for like where I'm
from yay we're known for so many great
things like the be in Jamaica I haven't
no I've never smoked weed you told me
that last time you were on the show and
I true story
but well then I'll have to go to the
professional here unless you want to
finish that well Tetra Hydro I can't
even say it yeah all right Mr Weed
what's the problem with these people
well that's what I try to tell people
you know it's been proven that AIDS
patients they use marijuana to helps
secur and this guy it cares cancer I say
imagine what pot will do for your flu
that's what I I take it when I have the
flu and I feel fantastic so uh it could
be because you're high though yes that
is why okay that is why that is great
really though what what about these
people what kind of psychotic person
would would tell someone that has AIDS
or that has cancer or some other
incurable inoperable disease that they
can't do whatever is within their human
power to do to to a mental defective
like Patrick Kennedy former congressman
from Rhode Island or maybe Peter
lawford's kid Chris Lawford who was also
an ex-heroin junkie who was now coming
on television to tell people they
shouldn't smoke pot so it's always the
guys who scratch their car at your party
and piss on your couch and then uh come
back when they're sober to tell you you
can't smoke pot anymore so that's who it
is and you know I'm not the first guy to
say this I saw a ComEd Nam Bill Hicks
say this one time about you know when
you outlaw marijuana it is a plant that
grows freely in nature so what you're
doing is you're outlawing nature you're
saying nature is wrong and that somehow
God up when he created The World
God created the world and it was perfect
and everything in it and then holy
I left pot everywhere now I have to
invent Republicans right
so that that was Bill Hicks so that's
exact that's the craziest that's the
perfect way to look at it you are going
to Outlaw nature something that grows
out of the earth is illegal yeah so do
we basically then just need the big
farmer to jump in on this and take what
he's doing and then once they can figure
out how to give you all the side effects
and you're having diarrhea and thoughts
of suicide and restless leg syndrome and
once they get all that down then they'll
be like all right we got it in pill form
and this crazy hippie doesn't have to be
squeezing it out of a little uh what do
they call those little little dropper I
thought there's a fancy science word
dropper thank you but really isn't that
where this is all going that once they
figure out how to put this in pill form
they'll all be an unlimit and and it
would never be as quick of a cure as
taking the drops it would be you take
these pills till you die from something
else in 30 years so we can make a ton of
money off of you it's it's it's
ridiculous that medical the medical
benefits of marijuana are seriously
being outweighed by legislation by rules
by law and law is you know we're allowed
to smoke cigarettes which have no
use at all but to kill your ass
but marijuana that is actually has been
proven or and and there's been so many
studies of what it does for you and how
it relaxes and people with high blood
pressure like all sorts of disorders how
there is so much medical application
with marijuana but no no no that's a
legal yeah so it it just tells you that
at the end of the day it comes down to
the agenda of corporate America they're
wanting to make money than wanting to
needing to be able to legislate that and
for me that's what makes it not just
Corporate America but corporations in
general it's people wanting to make
money and if they can't control and make
money from it they're not going to let
you get access to it and they're going
to make sure that you're penalized if
you try so from the from from the
corporate America angle to exactly what
you were saying the Bill Hicks uh idea
um is this just that we we can't do
things that are good for us because we
just we're so detached from reality you
know what I mean like we're detached
from the reality of the the corporate
part of it but then we're also detached
of the natural part it's this planet
doesn't even register with us right it
doesn't even like oh right we are out
inlaw that's like why don't you outlaw a
waterfall cuz cuz people can you could
drown any just to stand under a
waterfall we should make that illegal if
I catch a waterfall in your
backyard or GMOs they're worse things
that we're actively being fed every
single day yeah pink nobody no pink
slime nobody a problem with that nobody
you know because they're all getting
their their their the money off of that
they're all profiting vastly and
becoming million and billion and
trillionaires so they're fine with that
but God forbid you want to you want to
actually take consume something that
would actually help you and circumvent
paying them uh a monthly oh here's my
you know medical fee for picking up my
my my medicine from you when you
circumvent that you're a criminal can I
just say that she's the best not pot
smoking pot Advocate I I mean I knew
what I was going to get out of you here
but this this is impressive all right
bring us home and let me just give you
one more you know when you see these
guys like Patrick Kennedy and Chris
Lawford and they come on television and
they're advocating against legalized
marijuana or medical marijuana just know
that those people are being paid by
oxycotton producers okay that is true
they the salon or somebody or Mother
Jones or somebody the nation just did a
Expose and that guy Patrick Kennedy who
is a piece of who's been
going around demonizing medical
marijuana who's a drug himself is on the
take from oxycoton manufacturers so
always follow the money when you hear
somebody saying oh the and the marijuana
today is much
stronger and you know all that but that
is and they go you know we
don't need another drug no one's saying
we need another drug people are saying
the way we deal with the drug the it's
already here yeah the way we're dealing
with it is bad I it's your sh and also
the fact that there's so many I'm sorry
IAD my father was uh the deputy
superintendent of police for drug and
Firearm Administration in Jamaica for 42
years so I have a very strong
relationship to the idea of drugs and
how it should be legislated and what you
see is a lot of people in prison a lot
of PE you know our systems are
overloaded with crap from marijuana and
marijuana is the least problematic of
the drugs that are on the market and yet
it is the one that is the most demonized
so I have a huge issue with that which
is why I'm your biggest non-pt
smoking advocate joke I literally I was
watching I was growing a little weed in
my tiny little garden a little somebody
gave me a seed I was growing a little
weed and then I was watching Orange is
the New Black I swear to God and I
paused it in the middle and I ripped up
the weed and I was like I don't want to
end up in a women's prison you know I
swear to God that's true uh only a gay
guy would say
that on that note I want to thank shaa
and Jimmy Jimmy tell them quick about
your book uh people it's the funniest
book out there it's called your country
is Just Not That Into You it's uh it's a
good price go get it at Jimmy dooron or
Amazon wherever books are sold yeah I
read it and it is actually good I'm not
just saying that read go he did read it
here's a quote from the back from Paton
oswal Jimmy dors is outrageous outraged
bothersome bothered a crucial profane
passionate voice for progressives and
free thinkers in the 21st century all
right so there you go I would be if I
didn't let shaa pimp herself out real
quick talk to the camera uh um you can
find me on youtube.com/ heos I'm uh
auditioning and working and pimping
myself out apparently on the Ruben
report but I'm loving it all right there
you go thanks for watching guys and we
will do this again next
week